下歪太难了吧
生日快乐
生日快乐快乐天
你有看到CINDY欧尼吗
我要看他的衣服
CINDY欧尼的桌子
这哇小诶
卷起来了卷起来了
卷起来卷就说对啊
对对对对对对对
那个我有一个CINDY欧尼的小桌子哦
就是那个桌子上面都西是我高追啊
我们有个高质的团队
我跟你讲
你这完完蛋不行
就算了就算了
就不切了
不然就好像夜店诶
嘿这比较短
而且你还可以耍他
诶
嘿哈哈哈嘿嘿
只母这只是母的哦
因为他看见一片公的
就这100哦
对
♪ 我相信爱自有安排 ♪
♪ 我的美优雅盛开 ♪
♪ 漂流在爱情的海 ♪
♪ 你我也曾有过伤心 ♪
因为相信两颗心躲起来了吗
哎咿呀咿呀哈哈哈哈哈哈哈啊哈哈哈
吓歪了
川姐刚刚上台要拿水瓶子砸我
姜蓉姐一定很尴尬
这是她人生中最怕的时刻
你看娇蓉姐
你看看
We love you forever
♪ 我却逃不开 ♪
♪ Oh oh oh oh i ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ I'm ready ♪
哦的秘诀
我也我也不知道
我只想说选比较远一点的
应该会不会有机会太尖了
怕没机会啊
这太夸张了
我摔倒了
为什么哇
我在你隔壁看看
好帅啊
什么哈哈哈哈哈
太难了吧
抓到你
哈哈哈哈哭了笑哭的眼
好呼吸
♪ 甩开悲伤 ♪
♪ 生气想爆炸就大声唱 ♪
立起来哈哈
我立起来了哈哈OK梦和片里的你就要美美
依然没什么大不美
乖乖我是专辑的
我选了他
就是他
♪ 可以开了 ♪
五彩哦
呜呜哇
风水宝地风水风水宝地小姐不要离开
不要离开
风水宝地
哈哈你是厉害的嘉宾
田地对对
他
见不得你自己
我要把蛋砸了
我想说去你们那边不拉好
我不信战术啊
再次数不过三
数不过三
大家端午安康
那今天呢我想要跟你们分享一个
有关于双向奔赴的故事
小跟班是我的一位歌迷
他曾经在活动的现场或者是旅程中
和我见过几面
每一次他都站得不近也不远
就静静地笑着
不多话
眼神里面呢有一种很真诚
很专注的一种温度
我后来才知道
那几次相遇的时候
他其实已经生病了太晚
那他选择不让身边的人知道
不让大家知道
没有告诉其他的同伴
也没有在社群上说过
他只是默默的把他的病痛藏起来
把剩下的所有的力气都拿来支持我
完美
他在病重的时候呢
还是坚持参加歌迷会的会议
设计应援的内容啊
呃帮忙写应援计划
即使她住院做治疗
她都不曾缺席过
因为她说追我的演出他很快乐
他开心了很多
他觉得他的状态也好了很多
小跟班
你已经去了另外一个没有病痛的世界
再也不辛苦了
经理放心的飞吧
这旅途谢谢你
用那么安静却坚定的方式
把我放在你生命里这么重要的位置
我想我们不是一场单向的喜欢
而是我和你们之间一段真正的双向奔赴
今天这首歌我想要唱给小跟班
这孤单也唱给所有像你一样安慰
不知道替我在台上默默守护
默默支持的美梦境点
很因为爱
为让我们不孤单
谢谢你们
谢谢这孤单
♪ 太完美 ♪
♪ 包容不完美 ♪
♪ 像一颗钻石裹着脆弱的心扉 ♪
♪ 我对自己说伤心之后另一次机会 ♪
♪ 我会全心的奉陪 ♪
♪ 谢谢这孤单 ♪
♪ 的美 ♪